mercedes es sobreviviente de cáncer de
mama la cirugía y quimioterapia fueron
cubiertas por el seguro popular del
gobierno en la fundación de cáncer de
mama luego de que el estado eliminar el
seguro y los subsidios ella y otras
mujeres ahora deben costear su
tratamiento
para mí fue triste no que nos quita el
seguro popular y yo tengo que buscarlo a
veces no puedo porque yo llevé
quimioterapia es difícil para mí no es
difícil porque no es lo mismo cuando
estaba yo fuerte estaba ellos
100% sana
la fundación aunque ahora cobra directo
a las pacientes ya que el gobierno
también le recortó el convenio intenta
apoyar a quienes más lo necesitan dando
a precios accesibles las quimioterapias
y medicamentos
no tenemos suficiente ingreso no tenemos
trabajo no tenemos por eso fucam nos
está apoyando bajo costo en méxico 7 mil
800 mujeres murieron por cáncer de mama
en 2020 y además de luchar contra la
enfermedad y sortear el recorte de
subsidios algunas deben batallar contra
el desabastecimiento de medicamentos
la abogada andrea rocha ha tramitado
amparo sin costo para pacientes a
quienes les han negado atención o
fármacos ya llevados recursos ganados
lo más importante es que podamos
presentar el amparo de manera inmediata
porque el cáncer es una enfermedad que
no espera no le puedes decir el día de
hoy no hay una mastografía porque no hay
presupuesto andrea seguirá apoyando
legalmente a las mujeres que lo
necesiten sin acceso a medicamentos y
quimioterapias la atención oportuna se
está viendo cada vez más afectada prueba
de ello es que en 2020 se diagnosticaron
30.000 nuevos casos de cáncer de mama